hey everybody welcome back to css3 in 30
days
today is day number 10 and we are going
to be creating pricing table you know
when you download software our purchase
of product and there are different tiers
of options that you can purchase of that
specific product or service well we're
going to create one of those pricing
tables in css3 so let's jump in here and
see what the final result looks like so
here we have a basic pricing table we
have two options we have basic and
awesome we have the title of the the
card here and then we have the price and
then we have the you could see
alternating backgrounds we've got a
darker gray than the basic color darker
gray and then the call-to-action button
so these outline the features and the
benefits of the specific product and
then we have the awesome package which
includes more and it's just the the
reason why this one is bigger and has a
larger card and it stands out more is
because you kind of want your customers
to lean towards that option make it so
that both options are available but one
of them stands out you'll see it often
when you purchase a product and it says
this is the most popular option so they
want to highlight it so that all three
options aren't just monotonous and
there's a little bit of difference in
the pattern so it's a pattern disrupt
and it lets you focus on one or the
other specifically the one that is
better so we're gonna create that up
here in the sandbox you could see it's
just some basic text so we're gonna turn
this basic text into something really
pretty with css3 so if we jump over into
our sandbox you could see here we have
ten pricing table if the code editor
looks different to you I'm using
brackets right now Adam wasn't playing
Adam 8000m wasn't playing very nicely
with me when I was recording this lesson
so I'm switching over to my
second-favorite code editor which is
brackets and it's also free you can
download brackets if you like brackets
so ten pricing table make sure you
download that in the lesson folder that
will be available to go ahead and
download that ten pricing table and then
open
your sandbox that CSS for your styling
if you want to look at your index at
HTML you can see how the pricing table
works out it's just a series of divs
wrapping within each other nested within
each other the naming convention pricing
table we have pricing block header
pricing heading the pricing price and
then the currency value duration if I
were to scroll down to the final version
this might help you see it a little bit
better so for example we have the
pricing price the currency the value the
duration right here the pricing body the
unorder unordered list and then we have
the pricing footer which includes the
select button and and that's all that's
how that works so that's the HTML very
straightforward jump into your sandbox
and we're gonna start coding this up
right away so let's start with the class
of pricing - table
and that's going to be margin 60 pixels
Otto
let's go ahead and select pricing -
table
excuse me after pseudo-class
pseudo-element display table content and
empty string and clear:both okay let's
continue on we're gonna select the
pricing - table and here we're going to
use a child selector so this basically
selects dibs where the parent is all
dibs where the parent is the pricing
table so that is that selector and we're
going to say display:block we're going
to float that left we're going to give
it a width of 48 percent
minimum height of one pixel so it
doesn't collapse on itself background
color
whoops white that's triple F and then
color triple v save that in your browser
here you'll see that it's starting to
look a little bit like something it's
everything's floating each of these
tables or these divs within the pricing
table are floated and the background
here is that is white so it stands out
in contrast on everything else here
let's carry on pricing - table child
selector div and then the colon not
selector so basically this means a div
that is not and then you can give you
can pass in some information here to let
it know what it is not so for let's
let's break this down we're gonna say
not last
- child so this says select the pricing
table many children that are a div of
the pricing table but not the last child
this could be an ID or a class but we're
gonna specifically choose no not last
child because we don't want the last
child to have this style a nice little
css3 trick there margin right is going
to be 2% so on all those lives but not
the last child so really not the second
element
now we're going to say pricing - block
we're selecting that specifically
and we're gonna say text-align:center
border
hidden
now let's say this you can see starting
to come together we're starting to get
some basic shapes here excuse me if I do
with this random little coffee here and
they're just getting over a cold so I'm
trying my best to suppress it anyway
basic and awesome you can see that the
white and they got the the margin here
and the round border radius looking
pretty good let's go back here and now
we're going to select the pricing -
header the height will be Auto padding
30 pixels 20 pixels 40 pixels
text transform will be uppercase and
save that let's keep going is nothing
really that nice to look at quite yet
now we're going to select the pricing
header and then a descendant will be a
pricing - heading so in that we're
specifically selecting if you look here
in the browser we're specifically
selecting the pricing header pricing
heading so this is the header itself as
you can see but they were specifically
selecting the header within that heading
with it so basic and awesome is what
we're selecting I'm we're gonna say font
size
let's do 1.4 rennes relative to the root
font size and then font weight is gonna
be say bold
okay let's carry on let's select the
pricing price and that is going to be
the color of triple7 and then we're
gonna select pricing price child
selector span we're gonna say
display:inline-block if you go over here
to the browser pricing price is the
entire element itself pricing price span
is each of the elements within that so
the dollar sign the the the the dollar
value and the slash month text I want
that to be in line blocks so we could
specifically manipulate those items
those elements so now we're going to go
pricing - price double underscore
currency now we're going to say margin
top 10 pixels and below that we're going
to say vertical-align:top font size -
rim
font-weight:bold line heights just one
so we can keep everything nice and lined
up nice and tight opacity 0.6 0.6
okay let's move on we don't need to look
over at that right now
after currency let's do the pricing -
price double underscore value so that is
a numeric value
fontsize nice and big five RAM font
weight let's do bold I like bold really
highlight that price and line height one
there we go
so now head over to the browser and
check this out I'm gonna remove line
Hank and show you what just happened
this is what it was before without the
line height just the basic default baked
in line night for the browser but if I
add line height one its lining it up
nice and that's what we want
okay now head back here into your code
editor I'm gonna code up pricing - price
double underscore duration so this is
the duration of that price because it's
a monthly payment plan or a subscription
in this now in this example we're gonna
say margin top I'm gonna go 10 pixels as
well vertical-align:top now head over to
your browser I'm going to show you what
just happened there this is
vertical-align:top if I remove
vertical-align:top that's what happened
but if I add vertical-align:top it pops
up there and that's what we want we want
that to be up at the top near the
currency it just looks nice font size
1.4 ram line height again one to make
everything nice and lined up and opacity
for this one as well as 0.6 cool so that
is the price head over to your browser
and check it out that looks nice and
tidy the pricing and the title so let's
move down to the benefits and the
features here the body of the actual
price pricing table so now we're going
to say pricing - body and the unordered
list and that's going to be a list style
of none
just to remove that option margin:0
padding:0 save that keep going down
we're gonna say pricing - body ul Li
we're gonna go display:block padding ten
on the top and bottom 20 on the left and
right beauty and then margin:0
okay now we still got more to do let's
go down below that and we're gonna say
pricing - body UL li and then we're
gonna select the end child and then to n
that means every second child element
and we're gonna style every second one
like so now check this out head over to
the browser this is what's nice about
brackets and when you're doing the live
preview you click on the selector and it
actually highlights what you're
selecting so you can see in real time
what's happening and I like this so I
can show you how this actually affects
the enth child to end selector look how
its selecting every second child so in
the basic element there's only one
second child whereas in the awesome
pricing table there are two so it does
the every second element and if there
were more it would keep going so it's a
nice way of dynamically selecting
something a nice css3 trick background
color we're gonna make that white every
second one and then what we're gonna do
check this out pricing - body we're
gonna select ul Li and child again but
so what we're gonna add here is two n
plus one now watch this if we head over
into our browser watch what this does
so now watch what this is doing it's now
it's selecting essentially 1 3 5 so it's
selecting the you know instead of every
second it's doing every second plus 1 so
that includes the first one the third
one the fifth one the 7 and so on and so
forth
now we want to do is give that a
background color of we're gonna say
f8f8f8 just slightly darker a little bit
more shading now if we save that check
it on the browser it's very subtle but
it's a nice way of giving some visual
reference to each line especially if you
want to compare primary feature primary
feature these benefits these bonuses you
know and then so on and so forth it's a
nice way of outlining that okay now
we're almost done we're gonna jump down
into our pricing footer nice and simple
we're gonna say padding forty pixels
zero zero give it some space let's move
on
we're gonna style up our pricing button
comma that so we're gonna say pricing
button and then the link and then
another comma we're gonna say pricing -
button and then visited okay and in
there let's style it up like so
display:block padding twenty pixels
all-around text-decoration:none because
it's a link and we don't want that now
that style text transform uppercase make
that nice and uppercase background color
we're gonna say triple three kind of
that dark gray and then color white
alright so check that out in the browser
both of them look the same now we've got
our basic style but now what we need to
do is style that popular version the the
more popular one the the awesome one as
we called it so it's the class in HTML
is pricing - popular so the popular
option and we're gonna say this one has
margin top negative 20 pixels we're
going to bump it up a little bit to give
a little bit of an offset and now we're
gonna say pricing - popular and then
we're gonna do descendant selector and
say pricing - header and we're gonna
style that by saying padding top 50
pixels we're going to give that more
breathing room the reason why we're
doing that is check this out pop over
into the browser if I remove this
padding top because we have this offset
it's up here 10 pixels now we can't
compare and contrast each of the
benefits they're actually offset but if
I give this some more space I want this
primary feature to line up with this
primary feature so by adding our padding
top do you see what happens now it's
perfectly lined up so now if we keep
adding benefits on either of these
packages those are gonna line up and so
that's a little trick to do that just
some basic measurements and basic math
alright back in our code editor here
we're gonna go pricing - popular or
selecting that the whole time here now
and then pricing - footer now we're just
doing things to make it look a little
different padding top 60 pixels on this
one as well just more breathing room
and then now we're gonna do we're going
to go pricing popular pricing - price
the color of that price I want it to be
something that stands out FF 8 8 8 so
it's gonna be like a salmon color and
the we're gonna jump down below that and
we're gonna say pricing popular pricing
- button and that's gonna be background
color we're gonna use that salmon color
again FF 8 8 8 8 and the color we're
gonna say white is the text of that
button itself and now we want to be able
to have a hover State for that button so
pricing - popular and then pricing
button and the hover State and that's
gonna be color
we're gonna go FF 8 8 8 8 and then the
background so that's the text color will
be that but the background let's use the
same order background will be triple 3
the same as the default button state but
the color will flip of the text color
okay now save this check it out both of
them now essentially are done but if I
change if I try and make these
responsive they don't look very good as
you can see especially as you start to
get into like a
iPhone size so we want to fix that by
doing some basic media queries here what
we're gonna do is I'm gonna say a media
screen and max width 10 23 kind of like
a tablet and I'm going to style this up
by saying pricing table is going to be
margin Auto let's keep going
pricing table child selector div so all
divs that have a parent pricing table
float:none we want to remove that float
and we want the width to span the entire
container so 100% below that we've got
pricing - table child selector div not
last child so we're just going through
and re selecting what we just styled up
in our CSS 3 I'm going to say margin
right and we're going to remove that and
the margin bottom we're gonna say 20
pixels because now they're gonna stack
and we want 20 pixels of space in
between the two so that is gonna be good
let's keep going we're gonna say pricing
body we're gonna say max - width 100%
overflow:hidden white-space:nowrap so
let's see what this looks like so far
let's make this 10 23 roughly here there
we go so you can see now it stacks and
now looking here at the basic one
there's supposed to be some space here
there's 20 pixels of margin at the
bottom of this top pricing table but
it's not actually pushing it down and
that's because this awesome element has
negative top margin so we're gonna solve
that here go back to our code editor and
we're just gonna say margin bottom 40
pixels and that's basically just going
to give in another 20 pixels we could
have also said that the the popular
option doesn't have a margin top and in
fact why don't we just do that let's say
margin bottom 20 pixels but we're going
to specifically select
it's going to come up here but we'll
just jump in and add that style it's
gonna be pricing - popular and that's
gonna be margin top zero that'll solve
the problem there we go
about to get back to what we were doing
here with the pricing body
so after pricing body we're going to do
a couple do a couple more things really
quick and then we're gonna call that a
lesson so pricing body UL li
display:inline-block and then we're
gonna say vertical-align:middle
and then we're gonna go pricing - body
ul Li not first child and that is going
to allow us to say margin-left
negative five pixels what we're trying
to do here is you might be wondering why
are these stacking sideways like that we
want them to be a really short element
here but check this out in the final
version I actually wanted to scroll like
this so that means we need to give this
an overflow X scroll so let's go back to
pricing body and we're going to say
under overflow:hidden we're going to say
overflow X and auto that should give us
the option of when we are scrolling of
scrolling those features it's kind of a
thing that like Apple does and you know
it's kind of a neat mobile convention so
just to wrap up here let's find our spot
again so we did the first child just a
couple more things
we're gonna go pricing body ul Li and
child to n so every second one what's
happening background color it's going to
be e 80 88 just darken it a little bit
more just a stand out we're gonna go
pricing footer the padding top will be
zero to remove that padding and then
we've already did the margin top for the
pricing popular last not but not least
pricing popular and then pricing header
we're gonna copy that
and within that we're going to go
pricing footer so it's we're gonna
select the header and footer in the
popular element and say padding top 30
pixels done that's all the Styles check
it out in our browser the final result
we have their basic and our awesome and
every new elements here every new
feature gets added so that when you're
on your mobile device you can scroll
that left and right we've got them
looking good here and they're responsive
beautifully just like so BAM that is
super nice thanks for hanging in with me
that was a really really big lesson
hopefully you learned something and
maybe got some ideas to make your own
pricing tables thanks for tuning in stay
tuned for tomorrow we're going to be
playing around with some internet
explorer apps with css3
[Music]